i've been a hardcore windows pc fan my
entire life
and only just started to use and learn
about max a couple years ago
when i started working here at max tech
and six months ago i got my first
ever mac the m1 macbook air and ever
since then i've been completely turned
into an apple fangirl
and i can't blame myself one bit so in
this video i want to talk about my
personal experience with the m1 air
how apple stole the show and if you
should buy one
or wait for the upcoming m2 macbook air
instead which
by the way vadim made a great video on
so go ahead and check that out if you're
interested
and while you're at it click the
subscribe button below to support the
channel and help us reach our goal of 1
million subs by the end of the year
at this point nobody can deny that apple
silicon is on a whole nother level
and setting a standard that is nearly
impossible to reach right now
we've even noticed a huge change of
heart in our comment section about apple
it went from a lot of hate towards apple
calling them overpriced garbage
to now praise and excitement over
apple's new max because of their
game-changing architecture
and low pricing for the performance and
even die-hard windows fans can't help
but admit it these m1 max are so
overpowered that intel stole the macguy
and made ads trying to bash on apple and
it completely backfired
only showing people how desperate and
scared they really are now and if that's
not telling on how good apple silicon is
i don't know what is i have the thousand
dollar base model with eight gigs of ram
which by the way you can get on amazon
right now for only 8.99
which we have linked for you in the
description now nobody can deny that
this price point is
insane for what you get the previous
base macbook air also came in at 9.99
however it was almost unusable due to
its thermal issues
i remember editing a video that max made
testing the overheating issues on the
air
and the mac literally reached 100
degrees celsius
just playing back 4k video in chrome and
when updating fortnight the fans ran out
over 6000 rpm
and the system slowed way down and it
stayed at that 100 degrees celsius for
the entire time and
even when max manually maxed out the
fans it still wasn't able to cool itself
down
all of that was because the fan was not
connected to the heatsink
and it was that way on all of the models
you could spend 1250 on the quad core i7
model
and still not have the fan connected to
the heatsink fast forward a year
and apple's own m1 air doesn't even have
a fan
and completely smokes all of those intel
models getting over twice the multi-core
score
as the i7 this was important to me
because i need this laptop to do
occasional video editing and
productivity tasks
so not only did i need a thin and
reliable laptop but something with great
performance too
not only that but the m1 actually
outperforms every single mainstream cpu
on the market and single core
performance
which leads to basically the fastest web
browsing performance that we've ever
seen
so browsing the web is super quick and
snappy there was never a time where i
had to wait for my macbook
it always kept up with me which a
computer should while i use desktop pcs
my parents always used windows laptops
and those were okay for a while but then
they would start to slow down and have a
lot of issues
the battery health would completely
drain and they would have to have it
plugged in like 24 7
just to stay on i remember my parents
constantly having to buy new laptops all
the time because theirs would become
completely unusable and all they used
them for was web browsing and watching
videos
but after max gifted her a macbook pro i
never heard
a single complaint from her again the
battery life is incredible
the web browsing is super fast and that
laptop is gonna last her a long
long time and not only that but she
won't have to deal with any more
annoying windows bugs
so in the past six months it's now clear
to me that mac os
is so much more reliable than windows
since i haven't experienced
any crashes or weird bugs at all with
the m1 air and speaking of software when
this m1 air was announced back in
november
basically everyone believed that there
would be tons of bugs and issues with
x86 apps
but in reality rosetta 2 took care of
basically
everything and now six months later it's
shocking to see just how many popular
apps have already been updated for apple
silicon
and in my experience every single app
that i've used works perfectly with no
software issues
so i've been really impressed now
getting into some of the hardware of the
m1 air
the speakers are amazing they're very
crisp and clean and they're so loud
they rarely have to turn them all the
way up this used to be a massive issue
with my parents windows laptops
where you would turn them all the way up
and you would still barely be able to
hear them
especially over the fan noise and it's
crazy because we've recently got some
brand new windows laptops in the office
and even those have quiet speakers so
apple knocked it out of the park but the
even more
curious thing is that the speakers on
this air actually sound
louder than the ones on the more
expensive pro go ahead and take a listen
for yourself
and let me know what you think
now i don't use my webcam but i've been
editing videos here
for a long time and i've never seen any
webcam that comes even close to the
quality of the m1s
even though it's still 720p so all of
this comes down to the software
and apple software is unmatched because
the m1 chip comes with a dedicated
isp that fine tunes everything to make
it look great now as far as the battery
life
apple rates it at 18 hours of video
playback and 15 hours of web browsing
so you're getting more battery than you
could realistically use in a day and in
many use cases like mine it'll last you
multiple days before you have to charge
up another couple of additions with this
air
is that it now for the first time has p3
colors like the pro
so it's great for photo editing and
stuff like that and the new instant
awake feature is honestly a bigger deal
than it sounds when you use a laptop
every day
and if you're trying to decide between
the air and the pro here's why i went
with the air and why i honestly think
you should too first off it has so much
more bang for the buck
coming in at 300 cheaper while having
the same configuration
and at first we thought that the pro
would have much better performance
because of its fan
but the difference is so small that it's
not really worth the extra cash at all
since the air is still so powerful more
than most people will ever need
now there are a couple of downsides on
this macbook air for one
it only officially supports one external
display but for me
this isn't an issue because i bought
this laptop to use as
a laptop but if you really care about it
there are ways you can work around this
by using special software and adapters
now the other downside is that both of
the ports are on the same side
which isn't a big deal but it makes it
less convenient for me because my power
outlet is on the right side of my desk
so i have to reach the cable around to
the other side to plug it in
which can be pretty annoying but with
all that said i've been extremely happy
with the new m1 macbook air and i'd
honestly recommend it to anyone
even those who have never used a mac
before however the only thing that you
need to consider is that the macbook air
is getting a redesign
pretty soon and based on renders made by
john prosser and ian zelbo
the people have seen a real image of the
redesigned macbook air this one is going
to be really great we're going to be
getting new colors
likely the same ones that we have on the
24 inch imacs
and this new m1 macbook air is going to
be super thin
with a flat top and bottom instead of a
tapered design like the one we currently
have
and the craziest part is that we're
expecting a white keyboard in white
bezels
but i actually kind of like it since
this image with the black bezels
just looks a little strange and doesn't
fit the only downside is that it'll
likely be priced at 1200 and
up so if you don't have that kind of
money to spend i would honestly not wait
for it and just go for the m1 which is
on sale right now for 8.99 on amazon
the m1 is extremely thin and light
already and the battery life is amazing
more than you can use in a day the
performance is insane being more than
people will ever realistically need
and being almost just as good as the pro
and for that reason being a way
better deal and it's going to hold its
value extremely well for many years
there is no reason not to get this air
and i would absolutely recommend it if
you're on a budget
or if you're a college student and need
it for just simple productivity but if
you have some money and some time and
you really like the next redesign of the
air
that one is gonna be amazing and pack a
lot of value
simply for the exciting redesign alone
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did
click the like button and subscribe to
see more videos like it this has been
angelica with max tech and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]